Social engineering attacks are a
challenge to identify and to prevent.
These attackers are using methods that
are constantly changing, so we have to
be aware of the latest threats, and we
have to make sure that our user
community is trained on those latest
threats. Many of these social
engineering attacks will involve
multiple people across multiple
organizations, which makes it even more
difficult to identify and prevent. And
these attacks can be electronic, which
certainly makes them a bit easier to
identify, but very often these are done
by individuals communicating directly
with other individuals. This makes it
very difficult to be able to prevent
this from occurring using traditional
electronic means. Sometimes these
attackers will act as a disgruntled
customer, and they'll try to bully
someone into giving up additional
information. And some attackers will
take things that have occurred in the
news or things that may be personal to a
group in order to gain access to
additional information. For example,
we've documented cases where attackers
have identified someone in the
organization who has recently passed
away, and they will send funeral
information to the entire group within
the company, but that funeral
information is actually a malicious
link.
I get phishing attempts into my email
inbox constantly. These are attacks that
have a bit of social engineering with a
little bit of spoofing, combine that all
together and you have a way to fool
people into giving up private and
personal information. One of the ways
that you can identify phishing is in the
URL itself. If you don't recognize the
link, then you certainly should not be
visiting that link, and it's always a
good best practice to never click on any
links inside of an email message.
If you were to examine the website that
these links would take you to, you'll
notice that there is something not quite
right about the information you're
seeing on the screen. There may be
issues with spelling, there may be
unusual fonts that are in the message or
the website itself, and often you'll
find that graphics on the site simply
won't load properly. To give you an idea
of what might happen if you click one of
those links in an email message, I
grabbed an email message that was sent
directly to me about my Rackspace
service. You'll notice first that this
message itself was sent from someone
with an iCloud account. This does not
come directly from Rackspace.com.
This says, "Dear user, we notice your
email has not been confirmed for the new
upgraded service." No punctuation. "You
will be blocked from sending and
receiving emails if not confirmed within
48 hours of receiving this automated
mail." Notice the single line in the
email message has different sized fonts
and different colors of fonts. Then it
says, "You are required to confirm your
email through the link below." And
there's a big button to confirm email
now. If you receive this in your email
inbox, you should ignore it, send it to
the spam folder, and you should
certainly not click the link. On my
system, I clicked the link so that we
could see what the results might be. And
it brought me to my webmail login page
for my Rackspace inbox. Well, certainly
this is a legitimate link, so I can put
in my email address and my password and
click the login button. But if you were
to look at a Rackspace login versus the
login page that I was taken to, you
would see they were very different. At
the top is the email page that I was
sent to when I clicked that link in my
email, and in the bottom is the actual
webmail login for my Rackspace email.
You can see that although they are very
similar in their structure, there are
things that are very different between
both of these. And although it may not
be easy to immediately identify this top
one as malicious, we can certainly
compare it to the actual login page and
see that there are major differences
between them. I did not put my email
address and password into that fishing
link, but if I had, I would expect that
after the login prompt, it would have
told me that that information was
incorrect, and it might have even sent
me back over to the actual Rackspace
login page where I would put in my email
address and password, and it would work
properly. Behind the scenes, of course,
my original email address and password
has now been sent to the attackers, and
they're going to try using my resources
on this Rackspace email now that they
have those login credentials.
These fishing attacks are not just in
our email inbox, of course. You may have
many different fishing attacks during
the day that are sent directly to your
mobile phone. If this is something done
over voice, we refer to this as voice
fishing or vishing. You may have
received a voicemail that is describing
an important piece of information that
you need to resolve, and you need to
call them back and give them a lot of
money to resolve this. Or they might be
asking for security information, they
might be posing as your bank, or they
may say that they're with the local law
enforcement organization.
The best practice for any of these
situations is to hang up the phone. The
banks are not going to call you
directly, and your local law enforcement
is not going to ask you for money over
the phone. We also receive fishing
attempts over our text messages. This is
SMS phishing, which we also refer to as
smishing. We might receive a text
message that says that there are tolls
that we need to pay in our car, or we
might just receive a message that says,
"Hi, how are you?" from a phone number
that we don't recognize. And as soon as
you interact with that text message,
they now try to either get money or
information directly from you over the
text message. And fishing has
effectively ruined any type of public QR
code scanning because it's so easy to
replace a public QR code with something
that might be malicious. Generally
speaking, you should not trust any QR
code or the link that it takes you to
unless you really do trust that
particular link.
Attackers who are focusing on a single
organization have a decision to make. Do
they focus on getting information from
someone who works in the shipping and
receiving department, or do they try to
get information from the chief financial
officer? Obviously, the CFO is someone
who is going to have much more valuable
information than perhaps anyone else in
the organization. For that reason, they
might want to focus their efforts on
anyone within the executive team. We
refer to this type of focus as spear
phishing. They are targeting exactly the
group that they would like to get
information from, and generally this
information is very lucrative. Sometimes
you'll hear about spear phishing going
after a CEO, and because that person has
such control within the organization,
you might hear that referred to as
whaling. Attackers will go to LinkedIn
or other databases to find out who the
executive management is of a company.
They'll begin gathering information
across all of those individuals, and
then start attacking each one of them
individually to gather more information.
The CFO is a valuable target because the
CFO often has direct access to the
finances of the organization. They can
access and log into the bank accounts,
and they have controls and passwords
that the attacker would like to gain
access to. Spear phishing is a bit more
difficult to identify and stop, but with
the right training with your executive
team, you can keep this type of threat
to a minimum.
I was on a train recently, and this very
short trip allowed me to view
confidential financial information from
a third-party company, and I was able to
see pre-release details that were in a
presentation. All of this by simply
sitting behind someone who is viewing
this on their screen. This was shoulder
surfing where I was able to identify
sensitive information that normally I
would not have access to by simply
looking over someone's shoulder. So, if
you're in an airport, you're on a train,
you're in a coffee shop, or anywhere
where third-parties may be able to view
your screen, you may be susceptible to a
shoulder surfing attack. If you're in a
city, some attackers will take this idea
of shoulder surfing to the next level.
Buildings are so close to each other in
the city that you're very easily able to
see someone's screen with a telescope or
pair of binoculars from the next
building over. And some attackers have
found a way to do this from afar by
installing webcam monitoring software on
someone's computer and simply watching
their screen from a remote location.
Fortunately, shoulder surfing is a
relatively easy attack to stop. First,
you need to be aware of your
surroundings and you need to understand
that other people near you might be able
to see your screen. You might also want
to use privacy filters. If you're
sitting next to somebody on an airplane
or a train that are using these privacy
filters, the screen looks completely
black to you, but the person sitting
directly in front of the screen can see
everything very clearly. If you're in a
building or room where people can see
your screen as they're walking by, you
may want to turn your desk or turn the
monitor so that you're the only one who
has access to that screen. Throughout my
career, I've been to many airports and
traveled in many different ways and it
is very easy to be able to view
information on someone's screen when
clearly that information is meant to be
confidential and private.
A very common attack is one where the
attacker simply walks into the building
right through security. One way that
they're able to do this is by using
tailgating. This is when you are using
someone who is authorized to go through
that door to allow you access into the
inside of the building. With tailgating,
the attacker does not have consent to
come into the building. In many cases,
no one even realizes that the attacker
made it into the building. Perhaps an
employee of the building is coming back
from lunch. They badge in, they open the
door and walk through it, and they don't
realize that right behind them somebody
else is also walking through that open
door. That's the attacker taking
advantage of a tailgating opportunity.
Piggybacking is a similar attack, but in
this case, the person holding the door
recognizes that they are letting this
person into the building. This might be
an attacker as a box full of food or a
box full of donuts and doesn't have any
hands free and says, "Oh, please hold
the door and let me in and I'll deliver
this to the third floor." This is why
many organizations will prevent
piggybacking by putting a sign right
next to the door that says, "No
piggybacking. Everyone must badge in and
the door must be closed between each
badging session. Obviously, the problem
in many organizations is once you make
it through that initial security door,
you're able to have a lot of access to
the inside of that building. So, to
prevent someone from gaining even more
access to your internal systems, you
need to be sure that you prevent both
tailgating and piggybacking.
Some social engineering takes place as
impersonation. This is when the attacker
is pretending to be someone else. They
might have gone to LinkedIn and found
information about your company. They
could have found posts on the internet
where previous employees may have
provided internal details, or they could
have previously been in your dumpster
going through your garbage and finding
information about important details that
only people inside of the building would
normally have. For example, they could
call the help desk, say that they are a
vice president, and then provide
detailed information about that vice
president that they found when they were
going through the trash. This is
information that helps put the victim at
ease. How else would they know that
detail unless they were part of this
organization?
Or perhaps the attacker tries to confuse
the victim by using detailed information
and technical jargon. This can be
confusing, especially if they're
providing a lot of information in a
rapid-fire function in the hopes that
they can get that victim to provide them
with additional details or provide a
particular access to their systems.
Or sometimes the attacker just tries to
be a friend or a buddy and charm the
information out of the victim. Many
organizations will try to prevent this
type of impersonation by having a
certain set of policies and rules about
what information must be provided during
a phone call to provide the appropriate
level of authentication.
I previously described the process where
an attacker will go through your garbage
to find information about a company.
This is a relatively simple process, and
it is remarkable how much information
you can find just by going through
someone's trash. In the US, we refer to
this as dumpster diving because there is
a brand of industrial garbage collection
devices known as dumpsters. If you're in
the UK or Europe, you may refer to these
as a rubbish skip. We're generally not
finding pages of usernames and passwords
being thrown out with the garbage, but
something as simple as a phone list or
set of emails of employees can provide a
wealth of information to someone who's
trying to gain access to people inside
of the company. From there, they can
impersonate the name of the district
manager located in Cleveland, Ohio, or
they can pretend to be part of the
technical team that's developing an
application in Beaverton, Oregon. And
it's not unusual for attackers to even
understand when the next pickup will be
for garbage so that they can arrive and
go through your garbage before it is is
taken away.